في موسكو قال الرئيس ان بلاده ستنشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه على اراضي بيلاروسيا كما
تفعل الولايات المتحده في اوروبا اكد
قوتنا لموسكو جهزت 10 طائرات حربيه
بيلاروسيه لتكون قادره على حمل مثل هذا
النوع من السلاح
لا غريبه في الامر فالولايات المتحده تفعل
ذلك فقد نشرت اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه منذ مده
طويله في اوروبا على اراضي ست دول من
حلفائها في النيتو سنفعل الشيء ذاته من
دون انتهاك التزاماتنا الدوليه في اطار
معاهده منع انتشار الاسلحه النوويه لقد
ساعدنا زملائنا في بيلاروسيا وجهزنا 10
طائرات حربيه بيلاروسيا لاستخدام مثل هذا
النوع من الاسلحه
وتنحذر من تداعيات ما سماها الخطط
البريطانيه لتزويد اوكرانيا بدخائر من
اليورانيوم المناطق تمتلك مئات الالاف من
هذه الذخائر لكنها لم تستخدمها حتى الان
لا بد له من الاشاره الى ان لدى روسيا ما
ترد به دون مبالغه نملك مئات الالاف من
هذه الذخائر وحتى الان لم نستخدمها